einen schönen guten tag und willkommen
zu zdf heute live unser thema heute wie
sieht es aus bei den impfstoffen wie ist
der aktuelle forschungsstand
wann werden sie kommen und wer sollte
sie zuerst bekommen darüber sprechen wir
unter anderem nachher noch mit dem
bonner virologen hendrik strikt zunächst
aber schalten wir ganz prompt nach
berlin denn die pressekonferenz ist
bereits dabei zu beginnen wir hören ja
in spanien gesundheitsminister
forschungsministerin anja karliczek ist
auch dabei und der präsident des
paul-ehrlich-instituts klaus cichutek
denn da wird auch informiert darüber wie
der aktuelle stand in sachen
impfstoffforschung ist wir geben darüber
nach berlin der bundespressekonferenz
wir begrüßen hier regelmäßig vertreter
der regierung heute von bundesministerin
bündnis drin und die fonds präsident des
paul-ehrlich-instituts dazu gleich mehr
diese bundespressekonferenz ist und
vereinen den journalistinnen und
journalisten der regierung fragen
stellen so auch heute wir freuen uns
auch in diesen tagen als unsere gäste
beehren verschiedener sender werden
diese veranstaltung live übertragen über
den sender phoenix gibt es auch eine
gebärdendolmetscher für die wir sehr
dankbar dass wir heute zu dieser
bundespressekonferenz zur unterrichtung
der bundesregierung zu corona
impfstoffen die bundesministerin für
bildung und forschung anja karliczek den
bundesminister für gesundheit wenn
sparen und professor klaus cichutek den
präsidenten des paul-ehrlich-instituts
ein sie uns herzlich willkommen sie vom
herzlichen danke an meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren waren viele herzliche
tech weltweit arbeiten forscherinnen und
forscher unter hochdruck daran
impfstoffe gegen saas kopf zwei zu
finden und die bundesregierung
unterstützt diese anstrengungen von
wissenschaft aber eben auch unternehmen
einmal auf nationaler ebene aber eben
auch auf internationaler ebene
und ich freue mich sehr dass mein
kollege jens spahn und ich heute
gemeinsam über den stand der
unterstützung der impfstoff entwicklung
in deutschland und auch über die
sicherung von impfstoffen für die
bevölkerung berichten können
ich glaube ich muss an dieser stelle
nicht noch
weil die bedeutung von impfstoffen für
die eindämmung dieser pandemie im
einzelnen hervorheben dass ich ja nun
vielfach beschrieben worden und das
zeigt glaube ich auch das interesse
heute hier in der pressekonferenz
deswegen will ich es bei einem einzigen
satz an dieser stelle bewenden lassen
dass impfstoffe nach wie vor der
entscheidende schlüssel sind um die
pandemie zu überwinden
einmal in deutschland in europa aber
eben auch in der welt und deswegen ist
das was wir im moment hier tun so
wichtig und nicht mehr und nicht mehr
und nicht weniger geht es letztendlich
um ein globales problem mein haus
unterstützt die impfstoffentwicklung
seit langem
übrigens auch schon vor der korona zeit
seit corona gucken jetzt alle hin aber
auch davor haben wir uns bei uns im haus
mit dem stoff entwicklung beschäftigt
und ganz wichtig ist hier eben auch
unser engagement in der internationalen
impfstoff allianz aebi zu nennen die das
ziel hat die entwicklung der notwendigen
impfstoffe für die ganze welt zu fördern
und deutschland ist an dieser stelle ein
der gründungsmitglieder und darauf bin
ich gerade in diesen tagen natürlich
sehr stolz denn ohne cp wären wir heute
in der impfstoffentwicklung auch
weltweit nicht da wo wir heute sind
als starker forschung und
entwicklungsstandort sind wir neben
unseren internationalen anstrengungen
natürlich auch national in der
verantwortung die entwicklung
aussichtsreicher impfstoffe in
forschungseinrichtungen in deutschland
zu unterstützen
und genau dazu dient unser
sonderprogramm zur beschleunigung von
forschung und entwicklung von
impfstoffen gegen saas kopf 2 und genau
hierfür steht das fördervolumen von bis
zu 750 millionen euro bereit
unternehmen aus deutschland konnten sich
auf diese förderung bis zum 15 juli
bewerben ihre anträge sind dann von
einem
expertenrat begutachtet worden und
diesem expertenrat hat herr professor
cichutek vor gesessen dieser expertenrat
hat dann dem er mehr f die projekte von
drei unternehmen zur förderung empfohlen
und an dieser stelle möchte ich auch
schon mal für ihre arbeit lieber
professor sicher ganz herzlichen dank
sagen
im laufe des monats august haben wir
dann intensive gespräche geführt mit den
drei unternehmen die empfohlen worden
sind und dabei haben wir dann vereinbart
wie die förderung konkret aussehen soll
und wie sie dann auch dann sinnvoll
gestaltet werden kann
dabei hatten wir übrigens auch immer im
blick dass ein angemessener anteil der
produktion eines zugelassenen impfstoffs
für die bedarfsgerechte versorgung in
deutschland zugänglich gemacht werden
soll und die abschließenden gespräche
und deswegen setzen wir auch heute
gemeinsam weil dass es immer ein
gemeinsames projekt die abschließenden
gespräche sind dann vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium geführt
worden
mit zwei unternehmen konnten die
verhandlungen über die details der
förderung nun schon abgeschlossen werden
das eine ist die firma biontech die nun
von uns im rahmen des programms mit 375
millionen euro gefördert werden
das unternehmen hat sich unter anderem
auf die entwicklung und herstellung von
innovativen medikamenten auf basis von
messenger ribonukleinsäuren also guten
rna oder ganz kurz mrsa sowie zwar immer
in der öffentlichkeit verwendet
spezialisiert das ist eine neue
technologie und diesen ansatz verfolgt
es eben auch bei der entwicklung ihres
saß 52 impfstoffs zusammen übrigens auch
mit der pharmafirma pfizer der zweite
zuwendungsempfänger ist die firma covec
die firma covec wird durch das programm
mit 230 millionen euro gefördert und das
unternehmen entwickelt ebenfalls als
neue mittel und impfstoffe auf
basis das dritte unternehmen das bei
unserem programm gefördert werden soll
ist die idee biologika gmbh aus dessau
roßlau die firma idee biologika ist auf
die entwicklung und fertigung von
virusimpfstoffe virale vektoren und
biologika spezialisiert und der
impfstoff der hier in der entwicklung
ist setzt auf einer technologie
plattform auf dem deutschen zentrum für
infektionsforschung entwickelt worden
ist und die auch bereits in entwicklung
befindlichen meers impfstoffe verwendet
wird mit edc biologika sind die voerder
gespräche noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen
ich gehe aber davon aus dass wir da nun
über kurz oder lang auch die letzten
gespräche führen können und ich ihnen
dann eine positive nachricht vermitteln
kann
lassen sie mich ganz kurz auf den inhalt
der förderung eingehen mit unserer
förderung wollen wir diese drei
unternehmen in die lage versetzen ihre
projekte auf der einen seite breiter
aufzustellen und auf der anderen seite
schneller voranzukommen
zum einen wollen wir die möglichkeit
schaffen dass sie die einzelnen
impfstoffkandidaten möglichst
umfangreich und auch schnell prüfen
können
und darum fördern wir die durchführung
klinischer studien bis zum abschluss der
phase 3
nicht zuletzt damit eben auch zum
beispiel seltene nebenwirkungen
schneller erkannt werden können und
damit kann eben auch ermittelt werden
wie effizient und wie sicher der
impfstoff in den verschiedenen alters
und risikogruppen ist und dadurch wird
die entwicklung eines impfstoffes
beschleunigt ohne gleichzeitig weitere
risiken einzugehen
ich will ist an dieser stelle einmal
ganz deutlich sagen weil auch das ist ja
immer etwas was die menschen beschäftigt
sicherheit hat an dieser stelle absolute
priorität ein impfstoff kann nur zur
anwendung kommen wenn der erwiesenen
nutzen deutlich höher ist als die
möglichen risiken denn am ende werden
nur sichere impfstoffe auch von den
menschen akzeptiert und wir wollen
natürlich dass auch nur sichere
impfstoffe den menschen zur verfügung
gestellt werden
und von dieser linie
wir in deutschland und in europa nicht
abweichen und ich hoffe dass alle
staaten so vorgehen aber noch einmal
auch wenn die welt auf einen impfstoff
wartet riskante abkürzungen werden wir
hier nicht nehmen sondern wir wollen mit
dem sonderprogramm eben auch noch mal
unter einem zweiten gesichtspunkt für
beschleunigung sorgen und die
beschleunigung wollen wir dahingehend
organisieren dass bereits jetzt die
produktionskapazitäten der verschiedenen
unternehmen ausgeweitet werden sollen
die entwicklung eines
impfstoffkandidaten es ist ja immer nur
der erste schritt eine mindestens
genauso große herausforderung ist
natürlich den zugelassenen impfstoff
hierzulande aber eben natürlich auch
weltweit in ausreichender menge
herzustellen und dann am ende auch
wirklich zur verfügung zu stellen
entsprechend unterstützen wir auch die
firmen im aufbau von
produktionskapazitäten in deutschland
zum schluss natürlich hoffen wir alle
darauf dass in absehbarer zeit die
ersten impfstoffe gegensatz kauf 2
zugelassen werden und dann natürlich
möglichst schnell auch für alle die es
wünschen auch das will ich betonen
verfügbar sind und ich möchte betonen
dass wir in der forschung im moment
unglaublich schnell sind die
fortschritte zeigen leistungs zeigen die
absolute leistungsfähigkeit einmal
unserer wirtschaftlichen aber natürlich
auch unsere wissenschaftlichen
institutionen und das gibt uns immer
wieder mut und macht uns im moment immer
noch zuversichtlich den mut haben wir ja
schon von beginn an gehabt als wir
angefangen haben uns mit dem thema so
intensiv zu beschäftigen
aber und das gehört auch zur wahrheit
dazu wir sind nach wie vor noch nicht am
ziel mit dem stoff entwicklung in den
nächsten wochen kann noch ganz viel
passieren
nach wie vor müssen wir uns darauf
einstellen dass es erst mitte nächsten
jahres einen impfstoff gibt mit dem
breite teile der bevölkerung geimpft
werden können im moment ist ja die
impfstoffe entwicklung in aller munde
überall beobachtete verfolgen ja die
entwicklung alle gemeinsam mit
hochspannung am ende hoffen wir glaube
ich auch alle gemeinsam darauf dass die
drei firmen denen wir jetzt eine
förderung angedeihen lassen am ende auch
erfolgreich sind
damit wäre sowohl für uns als auch eben
für europa aber am ende auch für die
ganze welt eine große große
unterstützung und damit einen großen
beitrag leisten können
vielen dank ministerin herr minister
lieber herr fate of liebe frau
ministerin lieber anja lieber professor
sich meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren
impfen ist eine der größten
errungenschaften der menschheit mit
impfungen ist es gelungen in den letzten
jahrzehnten jahrhunderten fast viele
viele millionen aber millionen
erkrankungen zu verhindern zu vermeiden
viel leid und viel tod auf der welt und
impfungen macht so machen es uns möglich
mit einem virus leben zu lernen besser
leben zu lernen wären sind da und
bleiben da auch dieses virus wird
bleiben
entscheidend ist dass wir das unter
kontrolle bekommen das gelingt tag um
tag besser wir kommen aus einer phase
der absoluten unsicherheit im februar
mehr als wir wenig bis gar nichts
wussten über dieses virus wie richtig
damit umgehen im alltag aber eben auch
medizinisch klinisch in der behandlung
in vielen anderen lebensbereichen zug um
zug tag um tag woche für woche mit allem
was wir mehr wissen was wir mehr lernen
was forscher der ganzen welt aber gerade
auch hier in deutschland neu in der
farben bringen und entdecken können
jeden tag dahin aus einer absoluten
unsicherheit zug um zug ein risiko zu
machen mit denen wir umgehen können und
risiken begegnen uns auch ansonsten
häufig im alltag das ganze leben besteht
eigentlich aus risiken entscheidend ist
dass wir eben sie abwägen können mit
ihnen umgehen können und auch ein masern
virus ist ja noch da windpocken sind
noch da wir haben sie nur unter
kontrolle und wir haben sie vor allem
deswegen gut unter kontrolle weil wir
impfstoffe haben und deswegen ist die
impfstoffentwicklung gerade auch mit
blick auf dieses kroner virus natürlich
ein ganz ganz wichtiger punkt um
tatsächlich kontrolle über die lage zu
bekommen im stoff entwicklung ist
langwierig und komplex gehört mit zu den
komplexesten was es gibt in der
entwicklung
der medizinbereich sie ist schwierig und
nicht selten auch das gehört dazu
von rückschlägen begleitet umso
bemerkenswerter ist es dass in dieser
pandemie ist gelingt jedenfalls mit dem
was wir stand heute sehen wahrscheinlich
so schnell wie noch nie zuvor in der
menschheitsgeschichte bei einem neuen
virus einen impfstoff zu entwickeln wir
sind noch mittendrin die forscherteams
sind noch mittendrin aber mit dem stand
heute 15 september kann man denke ich
diese optimistische aussage durchaus
schon machen das hat damit zu tun dass
weltweit sich wissenschaft wissenschaft
leer vernetzen das unternehmen
zusammenarbeiten die vielleicht sonst
jedenfalls nicht so nicht zusammen
gearbeitet hätten und dass wir insgesamt
auf der welt auch in einer art und weise
zusammenarbeiten auch zwischen den
staaten
wie ist das so jedenfalls bei einer
impfstoffentwicklung noch nicht gegeben
hat und deutschland und das ist ja für
uns alle auch eine ermutigende eine gute
botschaft deutschland ist dabei ganz
vorne mit dabei mit den drei unternehmen
die durch die bundesregierung gefördert
werden wie gerade dargestellt bei
montech ihr weg und egt in dessau
übrigens alles unternehmen die
vielleicht vorher nicht so im fokus
waren aber eben tatsächlich sehr sehr
starke deutsche auf forschungsstärke
deutsche unternehmen sind
hauptziel dieser förderung ist es
natürlich dass wir schnellstmöglich an
einen impfstoff kommen und tatsächlich
damit ein unter entscheidenden
unterschied machen können
aber und das ist auch wichtig mit dieser
förderung und insgesamt mit der
unterstützung dieser unternehmen und ja
auch damit von clustern die damit
zusammenhängen er in der forschung in
der entwicklung in der produktion auch
darum geht es der produktionskapazitäten
zu sichern
stärken wir den wissenschafts- und
wirtschaftsstandort und dem
biotechnologie standort deutschland
insgesamt für die 20er jahre ich bin
stolz darauf dass durch unsere
forscherinnen und forscher hier in
deutschland durch die unternehmen die
sich daran beteiligten beteiligen
deutschland im internationalen vergleich
so gut dasteht in diesem rennen mit
dabei ist und zwar nicht nur aus eigenem
interesse für deutschland sondern unser
anspruch und deswegen
wenn wir uns daher auch international
ist ja darüber hinaus für europa und die
welt damit dem auch einen unterschied
machen zu können
dabei ist in zwei drei prämissen für uns
auch in der versorgung sehr sehr wichtig
aus sicht des bundesministeriums für
gesundheit und insgesamt für die
bundesregierung zum 1
und da schließe ich mich ausführlich dem
an was anja karliczek grad gesagt hat
wir erwarten sehr klar dass studien der
phase 3 klinische prüfung der phase 3
eben abgeschlossen worden sind und
erkenntnisse aus diesen studien
vorhanden sind wir sehen diskussionen in
anderen ländern anderen teilen der welt
die durchaus zumindest mal darüber
diskutieren und das zumindest auch
ankündigen sie russland auch früher in
zulassungen zu kommen und anwendungen am
menschen für uns ist sehr sehr wichtig
dass wir in phase 3 studien idealerweise
nicht nur tausende sondern zehntausende
freiwillige probanden haben weltweit an
denen und mit denen eben dann dieser
impfstoff getestet werden kann ein
impfstoff der wahrscheinlich so häufig
verimpft werden wird wie kaum ein
anderer impfstoff zuvor 100 millionen
wenn nicht milliarden menschen auf der
welt muss gut erforscht seien wirkungen
und nebenwirkungen
deswegen ist es eben wichtig phase 3
studien und zwar mit belastbaren
größenordnung von einigen tausend nicht
sich 1000 freiwilligen probanden zu
haben dass das wichtig ist haben wir ja
auch mit den meldungen aus den letzten
tagen über astra zenica gesehen das ist
durchaus nicht unüblich dass es solche
meldungen und vorfälle gibt kann der
professor sich rotex sicherlich noch was
zu sagen in der impfstoffentwicklung
aber es ist eben wichtig da gründlich
und vorsorglich mit umzugehen und
deswegen für uns ganz klar also drei
studien müssen vorlegen
das ist auch konsens in der europäischen
union ein zweiter wichtiger teil und
auch da fühle ich mich bestärkt durch
die entwicklung der letzten tage ist
dass wir von anfang an gesagt haben als
europäische union als deutschland wir
setzen nicht nur auf einen impfstoff
nicht nur auf ein entwicklerteam und
auch nicht nur auf eine technologie
sondern wir wollen ein breites portfolio
fördern und unterstützen und auch
vorausschauend unter vertrag nehmen als
europäische
union da geht es eben um die m r
technologie die jetzt bei den beiden
geförderten unternehmen chorwerk und
bayern tech eine rolle spielt eine ganz
neue technologie für impfungen beim
menschen wir haben die vector
technologie die vielfach erprobtes
proteinbasierter impfstoffe also
verschiedene technologien wo wir über
diese förderung hinaus auch seitens der
europäischen union und deutschland
zusammen mit anderen partnern da auch
sehr stark unterstützend in der eu eben
ein breites portfolio möglich machen
wollen die eu verhandelt mit unserer
unterstützung gerade mit 78 impfstoff
kandidaten oder herstellern
dazu gehören auch für weg und bayon tech
darüber hinaus eben astrazeneca ist ja
auch schon bekannt
weitere unternehmen und forscher teams
und wir engagieren uns da sehr sehr
stark weil phase 3 ist wichtig aber eben
auch ein breites portfolio ist wichtig
und was mit drittens wichtig ist das
möchte ich noch mal sagen weil ich immer
noch erlebe auch in den letzten drei
vier wochen in zahlreichen
veranstaltungen einmal mehr dass
gelegentlich anderes behauptet wird es
wird zu einer freiwilligen impfung
kommen
wir sind sehr sehr zuversichtlich dass
wir das ziel einer ausreichend hohen
impfquoten freiwillig erreichen mit
einer hohen akzeptanz für impfung wir
brauchen 55 bis 65 prozent der bürger
die sich impfen lassen um dort auch
insgesamt eine immunität der
herdenimmunität wie man es nennt zu
erreichen und das ist meine feste
überzeugung werden wir freiwillig
erreichen und wo freiwilligkeit zum ziel
führt braucht es keine verpflichtung
deswegen freue ich mich sehr dass die
förderbescheide an diese zwei dann auch
an das dritte unternehmen von insgesamt
750 millionen euro seitens des bundes
nun auch übergeben werden können und vor
allem das geld fließen kann das ist viel
geld geld für forschung aber und der
teile es ihm wichtig auch zum aufbau von
produktionskapazitäten und deswegen ist
es gut dass die unternehmen im gegenzug
sich bereit erklärt haben insgesamt über
40 millionen dosen als optionen für die
bundesrepublik an impfstoffen im fall
natürlich
der erfolgreichen impfstoff entwicklung
zur verfügung zu stellen das haben wir
im gemeinsamen vereinbarung
sichergestellt und ich bin den
unternehmen sehr dankbar dass das auch
gut und zügig möglich war das stärkt
unsere internationalen bemühungen das
stärkt auch die bemühungen im eu-rahmen
wir wissen nämlich sehr genau eine
pandemie bekämpfen das geht nicht allein
das geht auch nicht nur national sondern
das braucht europäische und
internationale zusammenarbeit und
deswegen ist die forschungsförderung
heute ein nationales projekt aber eines
mit internationalem anspruch wir wollen
mithelfen aus deutschland heraus dass es
einen impfstoff bei diesem virus für die
welt geben kann und diese förderung ist
dafür ein wichtiger beitrag
vielen dank herr minister hätten auch
wenn sie alle schon viel gehört haben
wird die förderung von links stoff
entwicklern und impfstoffe entwicklungen
durch die bundesregierung zunächst
überhaupt nichts für kommission cps
genannt worden
aber auch die währungen und viele
weltweit agierende stiftung tun wer
fehlt so hilft das vom bmbf
ausgeschrieben und aufgelegte
sonderprogramm doch noch mal sehr
zielgerichtet und macht deutschland fit
für die bereitstellung unbedenklicher
und wirksamer impfstoff produkte die
förderung hat gezielt auf wichtige
schritte zum verfügbaren impfstoff
produkt das für einmal die beschleunigte
entwicklung und ziel führen der
entwicklungsschritte inklusive erwähnt
hatte und ich hab mich müde häufig
erwähnt dass diese beschleunigte
entwicklung nicht einher geht mit einem
verlust an sorgfalt bei der prüfung der
entsprechenden land regel durch das
konditions tut und andere als neu
behörden genauso wenig aber bei der
entwicklung durch die entsprechenden
hersteller die ebenfalls die notwendigen
schritte einhalten wie üblich es geht
auch um den ausbau der
produktionskapazitäten und
gegebenenfalls vorab herstellung von
außenbereichen impfstoffkandidaten ich
darf noch mal erwähnen dass hier die
entwickler durchaus risiken eingehen
dann eine zulassung ist nichts was
gegeben ist wenn man nur die richtigen
schritte unternimmt sondern es gibt
immer unvorhergesehene ereignisse wie
wir das gerade erlebt haben
die zum stopfen können manchmal auch zum
kompletten abbruch
hier war es auch wichtig dass die
entsprechenden produktionsstätten
jedenfalls weiter genutzt werden können
wenn eine zulassung von einem der
geförderte technik nicht zum tragen
kommen würde
es geht aber auch um die nutzung von den
in deutschland entwickelten technologien
klar forschung beinhaltet viele viele
beiträge weltweite beiträge aber auch
sehr gute beiträge innerhalb von
deutschland die hier weiter gefördert
werden und die dann auch tatsächlich das
gebracht werden
was sie am ende wertvolle produkte für
unsere gesundheit liefern
es geht auch um das thema der
verbesserung der es der lagerung und des
transports der impfstoff kandidaten die
haben sicher die eine oder andere
bemerkung gehört dass hier
tiefsttemperatur lagerung und transport
notwendig werden kann ihnen versichern
dass er verständlich alle der drei
geförderten aber auch andere entwickler
arbeiten hier verbesserte bedingungen zu
schaffen passieren daraufhin wenigstens
auf -20 runter zukunft wurde sogar bei
etwas ganz normalen kühlschrank
temperaturen lagern zu können
das ist ein prozess und die
entsprechenden daten werden auch mit
unserer unterstützung geliefert
und nicht zuletzt geht es dann aber auch
die verfügbarmachung von millionen von
profiteams stoffhosen für die in
deutschland lebenden
ein ganz wichtiger schritt wir haben
vier valide forschungsanträge geprüft
sprich durch bei dieser gelegenheit auch
noch mal bedanken bei den kolleginnen
und kollegen des gutachter gremiums die
fachmänner verfahren war profis in der
arzneimittelentwicklung industrieller
hat aber auch der entsprechende
forschung impfstoffe klingen manchmal
trivial aber der wirklichkeit steckt
eine menge technologie immunologie und
physiologie dahinter und diese
zielführend zu entwickeln möchte mich
bedanken bei bmbf und bmg für die
möglichkeit hier eingebunden zu sein ich
denke das paul-ehrlich-institut hat hier
gute expertise
es wird manchmal übersehen bei einem
regulatorischen institut das doch im
grunde die ganze entwicklungserfahrung
von vielen entwicklern bei uns lager bei
den expertinnen und experten des
instituts die wertvolle beiträge allen
fährt zur unterstützung liefern können
und ich denke dass ein guter weg nach
vorne darf auch hier zu nutzen
da kommt sicherlich besonders zum tragen
das paul-ehrlich-institut ein
forschendes und wissenschafts getrieben
das arzneimittel institut ist damit
haben wir ein herausstechendes merkmal
nicht nur in europa sondern auch
weltweit nehme ich mich auch beton für
die gelungene ausschreibung vielleicht
war der eine oder die andere doch
erstaunt dass so wenige anträge gestellt
wurden
aber die ausschreibung war doch so tief
und so klar dass im grunde dann auch
nicht viele in frage kommen die weit
genug sind mit ihrer technologie die
entsprechenden kriterien erfüllen zu
können
ich glaube wir werden das ziel erreichen
nämlich die entwicklung der
entsprechenden produkte zuzulassen den
aufbau von produktionskapazitäten in
deutschland in europa die nutzung der in
deutschland vorhandenen technologien und
vor allem den ausbau unterhalt der
herstellung in deutschland vielleicht
kurz zu ihrer information stand der
geförderten entwicklung die firma biotec
hat hier von einem breiten portfolio
ausgehend von drei unterschiedlichen
technologien und unterschiedlichen
formen desselben antigens des proteins
von kona virus zwei inzwischen
fokussiert auf 1 2 im stoff produkte die
firma torweg hat sich von vornherein
fokussiert während biontech eine von
weltweit im moment 8 laufenden phase
oder besser acht impfstoffkandidaten mit
laufenden phase drei prüfungen und
stellt beim schuhwerk ebenfalls so dass
hier eine phase zwei kurven läuft eine
von 13 kann dann von fuel vehicles das
sozusagen die in phase 2 oder phase 2 3
prüfung sind bdp und der entwicklung von
ccs also von deutschland zentrum für
infektionsforschung zu deren
gründungsmitgliedern ist auch das paul
ehrlich institut gehört beginnt die
klinische prüfung nach genehmigung durch
das polnische institut wahrscheinlich in
kürze und wie sie wissen haben wir
weltweit damit die nase vorn
das heißt deutschland kann sich nach von
europa war fällt weg sehen lassen mit
diesen entwicklungen und um einigen
ihrer fragen zuvorzukommen möchte ich
kurz noch an
die zulassung hängt vom verlauf der
phase 3 prüfung ab sehr stark sogar und
die voraussagen die wir gerne mal von
uns geben aber auch andere dass die
ersten zulassungen des jahres oder
anfang nächsten jahres da sein werden
können zu treffen müssen nicht wir
dürfen darauf und dass ich hier sehr
positiv gestimmt bin hatte ich ihnen ja
schon erläutert auf welcher basis das
passiert die zulassung ist die
voraussetzung für die verfügbarkeit und
hier sind wir glücklich dass sowohl die
zwei ungeförderten kandidaten mit der
technologie erlauben das sehr große
mengen zehn oder sogar hunderten
in relativ kurzer zeit von wenigen
wochen bis zur form dargestellt werden
können beim vector impfstoff ist das
etwas weniger trotzdem sehr gutes
material und der erfolgreichen pandemie
bekämpfung hängt natürlich noch von
einer reihe weiteren faktoren aber auch
von den impfstoff eigenschaften der
verfügbarkeit und der durchimpfungsrate
und das betrifft dann auch der zeitpunkt
und dass abweichend von den baumaßnahmen
wie wir sie so schön nennen dass wir von
dem stoff eigenschaften abhängig zu
werden bekommen
also ich glaube ein gelungenes
sonderprogramm eine wunderbare
zusammenarbeit zwischen dem pf und bmg
und ich glaube da können wir
hoffnungsvoll nach vorne blicken das
sind deutet einiges tut und für die
gesundheit und die pandemie bekämpfung
durch impfstoffe hier und ausgezeichnete
beitrag geliefert wird dankeschön vielen
dank
also hoffnungsvolle stimmen von der
bundespressekonferenz ich fast noch mal
ganz kurz die wesentlichen aussagen
zusammen es geht also um den
forschungsstand beim thema impfstoffe
gegen korona bundesforschungsministerin
carlitscheck sagte noch einmal dass die
impfstoffe eben der entscheidende
schlüssel seien deswegen gäbe ist dieses
sonderprogramm in höhe von bis zu 750
millionen euro
von diesen werden jetzt drei firmen
profitieren
den größten batzen bekommt die firma
biotec aus mainz 375 millionen euro aber
auch die firmen cure weg und
ideologischer können sich über
zuwendungen freuen die forschung sei
insgesamt sehr schnell aber man solle
sich keine sorgen machen die
gründlichkeit werde deswegen nicht
vernachlässigt zu die
forschungsministerin der
gesundheitsministerien sparen hat gesagt
dass wir uns vor bleiben aber die
impfstoffe würden eben wesentlich dazu
beitragen dass man das virus unter
kontrolle bringen könne
die entwicklung sei langwierig und
komplex aber auch er war eben sehr
begeistert davon wie schnell in diesem
fall die forschung sei das hänge vor
allem auch damit zusammen dass weltweit
vernetzt gearbeitet werde und zwar in
einem ausmaß wie es vorher eben noch
nicht dagewesen ist er hat auch noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass die impfung
freiwillig auf jeden fall bleiben wird
die einschätzung übrigens der beiden
minister mitte nächsten jahr
also in etwa könnten breite teile der
bevölkerung dann geimpft werden zum
schluss klaus cichutek der präsident des
paul-ehrlich-instituts auch er hat sich
gefreut über diese beschleunigte
entwicklung auch er weist noch mal
daraufhin dass das keinen verlust an
sorgfalt bedeute und hat auch noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass die zulassung
letztendlich denn dafür ist sein
institut zuständig von der phase 3 der
erfolgreichen phase drei prüfungen
abhängt was das genau bedeutet phase 3
das werden wir jetzt gleich im weiteren
verlaufe der sendung noch besprechen ich
freue mich dass ich sprechen kann
darüber unter anderem mit dem virologen
an der universität bonn mit hendrix
träger ist uns zugeschaltet hallo da
sehe ich ihn auch schönen guten tag herr
strickherdicke sie haben die
pressekonferenz auch verfolgt zumindest
die wesentlichen aussagen wie ist ihre
einschätzung wir stehen wir denn da was
die suche nach einem impfstoff angeht
nun ist es erstmal sehr gut dass wir auf
breiteren füßen stehen und nicht auf ein
einzelnes produkt hoffen sondern jetzt
mehrere produkte haben neben eben
astrazeneca die drei produkte die jetzt
beschrieben wurden
generell das problem bei der
impfstoffforschung ist nämlich dass man
erst mal die phase 3 abgewartet haben
muss um zu sagen wie gut ein impfstoff
eigentlich ist und das kann man erst
ganz am ende leider in der klinischen
prüfung sagen wie gut es sein wird und
darum ist es gut dass wir auch auf
breiten füßen jetzt stehen ich hätte
noch ganz viele fragen werde ich ihnen
auch gleich stellen aber ich denke wir
sollten vielleicht mal klären was das
mit dieser phase genau auf sich hat
phase 3
die suche nach einem impfstoff die läuft
ja weltweit auf hochtouren nicht nur in
deutschland sondern eben auch in anderen
ländern
manche kommen vielleicht zweifel auf ob
eben aufgrund dieser beschleunigten
suche da eventuell ja manchmal doch die
schnelligkeit vor gründlichkeit geht
über den stand der weltweiten forschung
über dieses vertrauen berichtet meine
kollegin nina niebergall
es ist ein wettrennen an dem sich
forscher in aller welt beteiligt
wer entwickelt den ersten corona
impfstoff im rennen aktuell 241
impfstoffkandidaten und ständig werden
es mehr
fast 200 sind in der sogenannten
präklinischen phase werden also noch
nicht an menschen getestet
immerhin 42 mögliche impfstoffe werden
schon klinisch getestet das läuft für
gewöhnlich in drei phasen ab in phase 1
wird der impfstoff weniger als 100
menschen verabreicht gesunden menschen
um die verträglichkeit zu testen
in phase zwei mehreren hundert menschen
darunter auch corona erkrankten um zu
sehen wie ihr immunsystem reagiert
in phase drei bekommen tausende oder gar
zehntausende den impfstoff um
sicherzugehen dass keine massiven
nebenwirkungen auftreten und dass er
tatsächlich wirkt in dieser dritten
phase sind schon acht stoffe darunter
der impfstoff des deutschen unternehmens
bei und tag des britischen
pharmaherstellers astrazeneca und
inzwischen auch sputnik wie der
impfstoff des russischen galea instituts
obwohl der in russland schon seit august
zugelassen ist
eigentlich kommt die zulassung aber erst
nach den drei phasen und nachdem die
zuständigen behörden die
studienergebnisse geprüft haben
aber auch bei den europäern gibt's
probleme
astrazeneca musste seine phase-3-studie
zwischenzeitlich stoppen weil ein
proband krank geworden ist und bei und
tag die wollen im oktober die zulassung
beantragen
zumindest wenn alles gut geht
[Musik]
wenn alles gut geht ja das ist natürlich
die frage herr strick mit welchen
gefühlen sehen sie denn das rennen um
diesen impfstoff haben sie manchmal das
gefühl eventuell könnte da schnelligkeit
vor sorgfältigkeit gehen die herren auf
der pressekonferenz beziehungsweise
herren und damen haben wir das gegenteil
versichert nun erstmal wurde ja eben
sehr gut erklärt wie die verschiedenen
phasen durchlaufen und der erste schritt
ist ja erstmal zuschauen ob der
impfstoff überhaupt sicher ist und man
durchläuft eben auch so viele phasen und
damit man es erstmal auch an mehreren
menschen nach und nach testet um eben
auch zeigen zu können das ist sicher ich
bin überzeugt dass paul ehrlich institut
ist ja unsere ober aufsichtsbehörde für
impfstoffe entwicklung dass die da auch
sehr genau darauf achten dass das das da
nicht etwas zugelassen wird was am ende
vielleicht zu viele nebenwirkungen hat
ist es dabei am ende auch immer das
problem dass man ganz am ende dieser
phase auch es sagen kann ob dieser im
stoff wirklich sicher ist und ob dieser
impfstoff auch effektiv ist in einem
interview dass sie vor wenigen wochen
gegeben haben da haben sie gesagt ja man
sollte vor zu hohen erwartungen warnen
denn es gebe ja auch immerhin
krankheiten wie malaria oder es
beispielsweise gegen die ja auch oder wo
es aus seit jahrzehnten im prinzip um
die forschung nach einem impfstoff geht
und wo man den noch nicht gefunden hat
haben sie diese befürchtung in diesem
fall jetzt auch impfstoffforschung ist
immer komplex und wenn man sich da rein
denkt dann gibt es sehr viele fragen die
aufkommen kann zum beispiel einen 60er
jahren einen impfstoff wo die kinder
sich danach infiziert haben und man mit
einem mal eine überschießende
impfreaktion gesehen hat und zwei kinder
in den 60er jahren daran verstorben sind
daher ist es ja so wichtig dass es ganz
genau geprüft wird und man auch nicht zu
sehr hoffnungen darin weg weil es eben
sein kann dass man am ende da steht und
der impfstoff keinen effekt hat im
übrigen bin ich mir zuversichtlicher
beim corona virus impfstoff das dass man
da relativ bald etwas hinten kann aber
man kann wie gesagt erst am ende der
phase 3 sagen ob er
gut ist wie sicher er ist und ob er auch
in der breiten masse eingesetzt werden
kann
wagen sie eine prognose wann würden sie
mit einem impfstoff rechnen
ja ich fand antoni fauci von der ard in
den usa das relativ gut letzte woche
zusammengefasst dass er gesagt hat wir
haben frühestens im herbst ein impfstoff
der zu 70 vielleicht 75 prozent effektiv
ist und damit auch einen schwellenwert
erreicht hat der wo es sinnvoll ist auch
mehrere menschen mit zu testen
es kann aber auch sein und das haben wir
bei vielen impfstoffen erlebt dass ihr
dann immer noch kein haben und dass das
auch mehrere jahre dauert zum beispiel
bei den ihv da gab es ja viele
impfstoffe entwicklung die aber dann
rückschläge gezeigt haben und daher ist
es extrem schwer da eine vorhersage zu
machen
aber auch ich bin hoffnungsvoll dass wir
in die ende nächsten jahres da
vielleicht eine entwicklung haben
vielleicht an der stelle noch einmal
kurz der hinweis an unsere zuschauer und
user dass sie ihre fragen natürlich auch
an uns schicken können zdf heute - live
at zdf.de zum beispiel ist eine methode
sie hatten gerade gesagt dass sie auch
zuversichtlich sind dass mitte nächsten
jahres oder überhaupt im nächsten jahr
ein impfstoff auf dem markt ist
vielleicht noch mal die frage allgemein
was würde sich denn durch die
verfügbarkeit eines impfstoffes ändern
viele denken ja dann wäre alles so wie
vorher ist dem so nun das sind alles
diskutieren diskussionen die wir auch
zum beispiel auch den advisory boards
für die impfstoffe diskutieren und dann
sehr wirklich kleinteilig versuchen zu
verstehen was den einfluss eines im
stoff hätte
jetzt nehmen wir mal an wir haben einen
impfstoff der nur zu 50 prozent effektiv
ist das bedeutet nur jeder zweite
geimpfte ist geschützt
da stellt sich dann die frage für die
entwickler aber auch für die
zulassungsbehörden ob es sinnvoll ist so
ein impfstoff zuzulassen weil wenn nur
jeder zweite geimpft ist und sich
vielleicht nur jeder zweite auch impfen
lässt dann laufen zu viele menschen rum
die glauben sie sind geschützt
aber sind gar nicht geschützt daher
hängt es sehr viel davon ab wie hoch die
effektivität des impfstoffs ist wie
sicher sie ist und ob sie vor allem auch
in älteren personen die ja eigentlich
ein risiko haben für eine schwere corona
virusinfektion dass dieser impfstoff
auch in älteren personen funktioniert
eine frage von unseren usern ist unter
anderem die nach der masken pflicht da
vielleicht auch einmal ganz kurz ihre
einschätzung wenn es denn dann einen
impfstoff gibt wird die masken pflicht
trotzdem bleiben nun auch diese frage
kann man ja wirklich erst gut
beantworten wenn wir wissen wie effektiv
der impfstoff ist wir wissen im moment
in der hochphase der pandemie dass die
maske gut funktioniert dass sie
infektionsgeschehen vermindert und auch
die infektions dosis wenn sich jemand
infiziert herabsetzt ich hoffe selber
das ja zu einem punkt wieder kommen wo
wir den die maske nicht mehr brauchen
aber auch das kann man einfach nicht
seriös vorhersagen
wir wollen gerade noch mal hören was uhr
sahin zu sagen hat er ist nämlich sie
oder vorstandsvorsitzender von paion tag
aus mainz 375 millionen an fördergeldern
gehen an seine firma eine reaktion
darauf von ihm
es ist ja bekannt dass wir unsere
unternehmen das wenige unternehmen ist
welches in der entwicklung moment
arbeitet nun ist der mit unserer
impfstoff entwicklungsphase haben knapp
30.000 pro bahn ist in phase 2 studie
eingeschlossen und erwarten ergebnisse
von dieser studie im zeitraum ende
oktober anfang november das unmögliche
möglich das neue impfstoff
in greifbarer nähe ist entsprechend
dürfte das mit einer der hauptgründe
seien
warum wir brauchen wir durch dieses
programm mit besonderer förderung
bekommen soweit also uhr schein von
biontech vielleicht gerade auch mal
anknüpfend an die impfstoffe da stellt
sich ja dann auch immer die frage welche
bevölkerungsgruppe müsste denn
eigentlich anfangen was würden sie
vorschlagen wenn man dann einen
impfstoff hat es können ja nicht alle
gleichzeitig geimpft werden welche form
von priorisierung müsste man da
eigentlich vornehmen das ist auch eine
sehr trickreiche frage die wir auf die
auf den advisory boards für die
impfstoffe auch sehr diskutieren im
moment ein problem ist dass das
immunsystem auch altert man würde ja
erst mal sagen man sollte alte und
risikogruppen zuerst impfen weil die das
höchste risiko für eine schwere
infektion haben
das problem ist aber das immunsystem alt
hat über die jahre und im hohen alter
bildet man häufig gar keinen guten impf
antworten mehr aus dann wäre dann die
nächste reaktion ja dann ist man eben
die jüngere bevölkerung zuerst und dann
stellt sich die frage wie gut das
nebenwirkungsprofil ist und wie gut es
in der jüngeren bevölkerung getestet
wird eben in diesen überlegungen merkt
man dass es sehr schwer ist
vorherzusagen wer eigentlich als erstes
getestet wird da muss man sehr genau an
die daten oder geimpft werden sollte
muss man sehr genau an die daten schauen
und sich genau diese frage stellen für
wen ist am besten ist pokal check hat ja
vorhin auch angesprochen dass man
versucht das auch in verschiedenen
altersgruppen zu testen um genau die
frage zu beantworten ob ältere menschen
eine gute antwort mit gegen diese
impfstoffe noch aufbauen lassen sie uns
den blick noch mal ein wenig weiter wir
haben jetzt viel über deutschland
gesprochen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat zuletzt
höchststände an neuinfektionen gemeldet
ein wichtiger punkt natürlich neben den
infektionszahlen ist auch die
sterblichkeit infizierten dieses in
deutschland zumindest relativ gering
in anderen teilen der welt sieht es da
schon erheblich schlechter aus jan
frederik fischer
mit einem überblick dazu über 300.000
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
es ist ein weltweiter rekordanstieg die
in die letzten sonntag vermeldet
insgesamt haben sich jetzt über 29
millionen menschen mit dem virus
angesteckt
knapp 900 30.000 sind gestorben und die
lage in deutschland
hier sind die zahlen zuletzt relativ
stabil und nur leicht gestiegen im
schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 1.370 menschen
infiziert wichtig zu wissen laut lka
sind derzeit vor allem jüngere menschen
betroffen von denen nur wenige schwer
erkrankten die zahl der krankenhausfälle
ist in deutschland daher zuletzt stark
gesunken und liegt nun bei 5 prozent
die zahl der verstorbenen nahm nach
einem füllstand im april ab und bleibt
seit wochen auf einem sehr niedrigen
niveau
die eu hat zuletzt davor gewarnt dass es
im herbst wieder zu höheren zahlen
kommen wird was die sterblichkeit angeht
auch in europa auch in deutschland
teilen sie diese befürchtung die
befürchtung teile ich auch ich rechne
auch damit das wir sehr hohe
infektionszahlen bekommen werden das ist
einfach die natur der sache dieses virus
dass sie dass wir einmal enger
beieinander sind in den innenräumen sind
sich dort das virus besser verteilen
kann besser übertragen werden kann und
wir dadurch eben auch mehr fälle in den
familien sehen auch bei in der älteren
bevölkerung und das vielleicht auch ins
pflegeheim getragen wird daher ist
gerade die der winter und der herbst
eine kritische phase in der pandemie und
aber wir haben trotz allem sehr viele
daten gesammelt in den letzten sechs
monaten und wir verstehen mittlerweile
sehr gut worauf wir achten müssen wie
wir das virus kontrollieren können und
vor allem auch wie sich das
infektionsgeschehen sowohl in den
verschiedenen bevölkerungsschichten
verhält aber auch wie viele zum beispiel
von den erkrankten von bestimmten
altersgruppen dann auch stationär
behandelt werden können davon ausgehen
können ja eigentlich mittlerweile sehr
gute prognose
erstellen an gegen uns lang handeln
können da an denen wir uns richten
können um zu um weiter auch lockerungen
oder maßnahmen zu beschließen und daher
denke ich würde es auch wichtig werden
dass wir diese faktoren also die
intensivmedizinische belegung die
stationäre belegung die anzahl der test
und die infektionszahlen bündeln und
danach das weitere vorgehen beschließen
weil alleine die infektionszahlen gerade
wenn es nur in der jüngeren bevölkerung
ist letztendlich nicht so
ausschlaggebend ist für die pandemie
sondern vielmehr auch die stationäre
belegung weil es am ende darauf ankommt
dass jeder bürger auch die bestmögliche
gesundheitliche versorgung in den
krankenhäusern bekommt guter zu diesem
punkt ansprechen darauf wäre ich jetzt
als nächstes auch nochmal zu sprechen
gekommen sie haben das auch schon in
einem interview einem zeitungsinterview
gesagt das ist eben alleine auf die
infektionszahlen nicht ankomme weil eben
diese hohe sterblichkeit ja so nicht
eingetreten sei bislang dieser ansatz
von ihnen ist kritisiert worden unter
anderem auch von gesundheitsexperten der
spd karl lauterbach ich will sie ganz
kurz konfrontieren mit seiner reaktion
auf twitter er hatte gesagt richtig ist
unsere reaktion auf die zweite welle
breit zu diskutieren
aber die annahme von ihnen von professor
strickteile ich nicht das ist bei
leichten fällen bleiben wird steigende
krankenhausfälle in frankreich spanien
dem vereinigten königreich israel weisen
in eine andere richtung und weiter unten
ist er noch zu vernehmen mit den worten
wenn wir erst warten bis die zahl der
toten wieder gestiegen es laufen wir der
pandemie hinterher
man stimmt meist vier wochen nach der
infektion vorbeugung geht so nicht
auch ist der tod nur die spitze des
eisbergs auf jeden der stirbt werden
vier weitere zum teil lange beatmet was
entgegnen sie herrn lauterbach hatte sie
falsch verstanden oder sind sie
tatsächlich inhaltlich nicht einer
meinung
wie so oft hat er lauterbach leider das
interview nicht gelesen sondern ich sage
ja gerade nicht dass wir uns von den
infektionszahlen deck wenden sollen
sondern wir müssen alles im blick nehmen
wir müssen die stationäre belegung im
blick nehmen die intensivmedizinische
belegung die anzahl der test
durchgeführt werden und die positiven
rate also wie
viele der test eigentlich am ende
positiv sind ich nehme ja auch an wie
wir das vorhin gehabt haben gesprochen
haben dass die anzahl der schweren fälle
wieder ansteigen wird da widersprechen
wir uns überhaupt nicht sondern dass wir
am besten durch so eine pandemie
durchgehen wenn wir auch in einer
umfassenden blick nehmen und uns nicht
nur darauf beschränken wie viele
infektionszahlen es kommt es ist ja
einleuchtend dass wenn wir bei
fünfprozentiger stationärer belegung im
moment nur sind durch kurven 19
dass diese fünf prozent ein viel
wichtiger faktor im moment sind weil die
symptomatische infektion also die
infektion ohne symptome ja kein einfluss
oder keinen großen einfluss auf das
pandemien geschehen haben an der stelle
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz der
einschub also der
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen hat
ja auch von einer priorisierung
gesprochen er sagte erst die älteren
menschen impfen dann die risikogruppen
ärzte und pflegekräfte würden sie die
man etwa zustimmen
nein also prinzipiell ist das eine gute
vorgehensweise mit der fußnote die man
daran setzen muss dass man sehen muss
wie gut der impfstoff bei älteren
menschen und bei risikogruppen noch
anschlägt das wissen wir eben nicht und
aber prinzipiell wenn alle gleich gut
auf den impfstoff reagieren wäre das der
richtige weg dass man genau in dieser
reihenfolge ältere menschen
risikogruppen ärzte und pflegepersonal
und dann der rest der bevölkerung impfen
der beste weg weil man dadurch die die
am meisten gefährdet sind auch am besten
schützt noch mal kurz zu der
sterblichkeit herr professor strikt laut
robert-koch-institut starben in der
woche vom 13 april 1208 patienten
ankommt 19 drei monate später nur noch
33 und in der vergangenen woche sogar
weniger als 10
wie ist es eigentlich zu erklären das
fragen sich auch viele unserer user dass
die sterblichkeit bei uns inzwischen so
gering ist
nun das wird wahrscheinlich
multifaktoriell sein und einen faktor
haben sie eben schon mal angesprochen
nämlich dass das vor allem in der
jüngeren bevölkerung sich im moment
ausbreitet wir wissen dass die meisten
dort sehr gut mit der infektion
und auch er ein treffer haben ohne
symptome
zusätzlich sind wir im sommer virale neu
monin also schwere virus
lungenentzündungen treten im sommer fast
nie auf das ist ein phänomen was wir
eben aus anderen viralen erkrankungen
können aber auch was hier im moment
machen unser verhalten also abstand
halten hände hygiene regeln und alltags
masken verringern wahrscheinlich die
infektions dosis bei der ersten
infektion
was ich damit sagen will ist dass wenn
man das hier von anderen viralen
erkrankungen die von saas und mehr sind
ihr versuch aber auch bei der grippe im
versuch mit dem menschen herausgefunden
haben dass wenn man mit vielen tieren am
anfang konfrontiert wird dass man dann
einen schweren verlauf hat aber wenn man
wenig wären nur abbekommt dass man dann
einen milden oder ein verlauf ohne
symptome hat was wir machen durch unsere
verhaltensweisen ist dass wir die
infektions dosis wahrscheinlich
heruntersetzen das wurde in einer
publikation vor kurzem auch
vorgeschlagen
und wir tragen wahrscheinlich alle dafür
war dazu bei dass wir weniger
sterbefälle derzeit von co mit 19 haben
sondern mehr wenn wir einen anstieg
haben eigentlich von verläufen ohne
symptome
also auch noch mal ein klares plädoyer
von ihrer seite für die a-ha regeln wenn
sie das richtig verstanden habe das ist
ja auf jeden fall sinnvoll die bereits
genau so lange es noch keinen corona
impfschutz es gibt wie wichtig ist es
denn eigentlich sich gegen die viren
impfen zu lassen
die bekannt sind also ich hätte zum
beispiel von der grippe das hat
wahrscheinlich zwei effekte also einmal
dritte impfung hat den vorteil dass wenn
sich viele menschen im moment grippe
impfen lassen
und wir eine grippewelle haben sollten
ist es ja nicht gesichert dass wir eine
bekommen werden dass wir zumindest diese
menschen nicht im krankenhaus sehen und
keine schweren grippe verläuft haben
also man trägt etwas dazu bei dass das
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
im herbst und winter
der zweite punkt und der ist bisher noch
nicht wissenschaftlich erwiesen viele
gruppen arbeiten daran
ob eine ein kreuz schutz entsteht
zwischen einer grippeimpfung und 19
infektion
das mag jetzt erstmal nicht intuitiv
sein aber man nimmt an dass das
immunsystem gepustet wird durch also
oder mehr im alarmstufe ist durch eine
grippeimpfung und man sich dadurch für
eine kurze zeit weniger mit anderen
viralen erkrankungen infiziert
vielleicht noch wichtiger ist auch das
ja ich wollte nur sagen vielleicht ein
ganz kurzer bericht er ist auch ein
chopin strikt erlauben sie mir ganz kurz
die nachfrage weil unsere user doch
immer wieder fragen und das sind
natürlich auch viele dabei die sich
kritisch äußern
gegenüber impfstoffen im allgemeinen und
vielleicht können sie noch einmal ganz
kurz sagen warum es sinnvoll ist aus
ihrer sicht eben doch zu impfen auch
wenn dann der impfstoff gegen korona
gegen chur wird
erhältlich ist nun generell konnten wir
kannten ihn oder infektionserregern nur
über impfstoffe kontrollieren
das beste beispiel ist der brocken im
stoff der hat die menschheit für jahre
geplagte jahrzehnte geplagt und wurde
sogar als biowaffe im alten china schon
eingesetzt und man muss sich vorstellen
dass jeder fünfte an pocken verstorben
ist und man hatte keine mittel
dann kam der pocken impfstoff und
mittlerweile sind die brocken
ausgerottet also ist es eine der
billigsten aber auch effektivsten
methoden um sich gegen impfstoffe zu
gehen um sich gegen erreger zu wärmen im
grunde ist ein impfstoff eigentlich nur
ein training des immunsystems also so
wie man dann eben eine fußball
mannschaft trainiert trainiert man das
immunsystem das sie dann besser
vorbereitet sind wenn der gegner mal
klar auf einen trifft also ich bin
selber seit über zehn jahren lasse ich
mich gegen grippe impfen und hat nie
irgendwelche folgen davon gehabt und bin
auch ein überzeugter in fan gut das sind
nochmal klare worte zum abschluss vielen
dank herr professor stricks oder so die
panini das denke ich ist keine allzu
gewagte prognose wird uns noch eine
ganze weile begleiten ob mit oder ohne
impfstoff und es wird natürlich
man auch um die frage gehen wie ist der
richtige umgang damit medizinisch und
natürlich auch gesellschaftlich vielen
dank dass sie zeit hatten für uns und
für dieses gespräch zur verfügung
gestanden haben dankeschön
vielen dank ja so weit heute live auch
an unsere zuschauer und user natürlich
nochmal besten dank auch für die fragen
und kommentare
wir wünschen euch einen schönen tag
sagen dass bald und auf wiedersehen